Hey everyone, welcome back to the
channel. For those of you who are new,
I'm Evan. I'm a former Meta staff
engineer and the current co-founder of
hellointerview.com. If you're preparing
for software interviews, head over to
hellointerview. We got everything you
need, overwhelming majority of which is
free.
Uh in this particular video though,
we're going to be covering the basics of
caching, and specifically in the context
of system design interviews. And so,
we'll look at where caching fits into a
system. We'll talk about the most common
caching architectures, typical eviction
policies you want to understand. We're
also going to talk about the kinds of
issues that show up when you introduce
caching. These are things like
consistency, stampedes, hot keys, the
things that interviewers really love to
dig into and that you'll want to be
prepared for. And then finally, we'll go
over how to talk about caching in an
interview, when to bring it up, how much
depth you should go you should go into.
And the things that interviewers are are
usually looking for. So, this should be
fun. Without further ado, let's get
after it. Chances are you already have a
pretty decent idea of what caching is.
Uh but let's go ahead and start from
just the very basics really quickly to
make sure that everybody's on the same
page.
And so, a cache is quite simply just a
temporary storage that keeps recently
used data handy and close by so that you
can fetch it faster the next time.
So, to see why this matters, let's take
a look at an example here. And consider
the difference in speed between where
data usually lives in a database and
where it can live in a cache.
And so, accessing data from disk, like
an SSD in the case of a database, takes
about a millisecond on average.
Accessing data from memory or RAM on the
other hand takes about 100 nanoseconds.
This is roughly 10,000 times faster.
Now, that gap adds up really quickly
when you're serving thousands of
requests per second. And caching takes
advantage of that big difference. It
keeps copies of frequently used data in
a faster layer, often times memory, but
not always. We'll talk about that later
on. So, that systems don't have to reach
all the way back into that slower source
every single time.
So, you have the basic idea. Caching
trades a bit of storage and complexity
for speed.
Now, the next question is, where should
you cache your data? And there's a few
different layers in your system where
caching can live, each of which have
their own set of trade-offs, of course.
And so, the first one, and by far the
most common in system design interviews,
is called external caching.
This is where you introduce a dedicated
caching service like Redis or Memcached.
It runs, importantly, on its own server
and manages its own memory, and it's
totally separate from your application
or your database, right? It's your own
component in the system here.
And so, when your application needs
data, it first checks the cache. If the
data is found there, that's a cache hit,
and it returns your data instantly,
super fast. If it's not there, we call
that a cache miss, and it has to fall
back to the database, fetch the data,
and it stores a copy of that data back
in the cache, and also returns it back
to the client, right?
Uh now, the nice thing here is that in a
scaled system, which might have multiple
application servers like we represented
here, all of these different application
servers can share that same external
cache.
This way, once one server has fetched
and cached the data, the others can all
reuse it instantly instead of all
hitting the database separately, right?
Because this is a global view. It's a
global cache that's shared by all of the
different application servers.
Now, the second option
is what we call in-process caching.
And this lets you skip the complexity of
adding something like Redis entirely. Uh
it's often overlooked, to be honest, and
I think in real system design outside of
the context of interviews, it's probably
overlooked more than it should be, but
it can be incredibly effective.
Now, the key thing to note here is that
modern application servers usually run
on really big machines nowadays that
have plenty of memory. And you can
actually use some of that memory in
order to cache data right inside of the
process.
Uh this is important because it's by far
the fastest kind of caching, right? You
don't have to go and have an expensive
network hop here to hit some external
cache anymore. The data is already
sitting in the same memory space as your
application, right? So, you don't have
that expensive network hop, it's already
right there where you want it. But of
course, this this comes with trade-offs.
And the main trade-off is that unlike
the external cache, each application
server has its own in-process memory.
And so, this means that if one server
caches something, the others won't see
it. So, you can end up with these
inconsistencies or even wasted memory if
you're not too careful.
And so, the chances are, at least in the
context of a system design interview,
that you probably won't need to bring
this up unless you're talking about a
low-level optimization or have a use
case where ultra low latency matters.
For example, if you need to cache config
data or small lookup tables that every
single request depends upon, then
caching within the application server
makes sense, but your default should
remain as external caching. Next up, we
have what are called CDNs or content
delivery networks.
And so, a CDN is a geographically
distributed network of servers that can
cache content closer to your users. And
I know that that sounds fancier really
than it is. It's just putting servers
around the world so that they're close
to the people who need them. Here, we're
not optimizing for the difference
between memory and disk speeds like we
were before. Instead, we're optimizing
for network latency.
So, without a CDN, every single request
has to travel all the way to your origin
server.
If you had a server in Virginia, like
was the case here, think that this is S3
or some blob storage, right? And your
user is all the way over here in
Australia, then this round trip could
take 300 to 350 milliseconds. That's
huge, especially when we're talking
about disk access being just 1
millisecond.
With a CDN on the other hand, that same
request might hit an edge server that's
just a few miles away, which may be 20
to 40 milliseconds round trip, which is
a huge difference.
Now, the way that it works is that when
a user requests something like an image,
that request goes to the nearest CDN
edge server like we just said. And if
that image is already cached there, it's
returned immediately. Perfect, that's
the happy case, that's the cache hit.
If not, if it's a cache miss, then the
CDN itself goes and fetches that media
or whatever you're looking for from uh
your origin server, like S3 or whatever
blob storage you have, and then it's
going to return that back to the CDN.
The CDN will then cache it so that it
has it for next time and return it back
to the client.
Now, modern CDNs, and this is something
people often times forget, they can do a
lot more than just cache static media,
which is what they're most known for.
They can also cache public API
responses, of course HTML pages, run
edge logic even to personalize content.
But as far as a system design interview
goes, the most common and the most
impactful use case to bring up is on
media delivery. So, things like images,
videos, or static assets, files, etc.
that you want to load really quickly
around the world. And so, if you have
global users who are accessing media
regularly, then a CDN is probably a
great fit for you.
Lastly, we have what's called
client-side caching.
So, this is when data is stored directly
on the user's device, either in the
browser or the app, which avoids
unnecessary network costs. Um
So, in web apps, that might be something
like the HTTP cache or local storage
within the browser itself. For mobile
apps, this could be data kept in memory
or even written to the local disk on
device.
And it's nice cuz it's obviously super
fast. Data never leaves the device. But
it comes with the downside, of course,
and that's that you have less control
over it. Data can go stale, validation,
freshness, all of that is a bit harder.
And so, when it comes to your interview,
you'll see this come up a lot less
often. Um usually, it's only relevant
when your system involves some offline
functionality or client-heavy workloads.
For example, if a browser's reusing
images it already downloaded, or an app
like Strava caching your run data
locally while you're offline and then
syncing it once you're reconnected. We
have a problem breakdown where we do
exactly that. But for all intents and
purposes, this is the least important
for you to know as it pertains to your
system design interviews.
Really quick, before we continue, let me
tell you a little bit about the most
popular feature on hellointerview.com,
guided practice.
It's an interactive tool that lets you
practice system design interview
step-by-step using that hello interview
delivery framework. You're going to walk
through everything from the
non-functional requirements to the core
entities, API routes, all the way
through to your high-level design and
deep dives, drawing on the whiteboard
and narrating your response. All while
getting real-time feedback on what
you're doing well and where you can
improve by a model that Stefan and I
have spent hundreds of hours tuning.
We expanded the library to 25 of the
most common system design interview
questions now, and we're constantly
adding more. So, candidates absolutely
love this feature. I think you will,
too. Check it out at hellointerview.com.
Link will be in the description. Now
that we've covered where you can cache
your data, let's talk a little about
cache architectures.
Cache architecture is just defined how
your application actually interacts with
the cache. And so, specifically, this is
defining the order in which reads and
writes happen between both your cache
and your database and your application
servers.
And so, the most common caching pattern
by far, and this is the one that you
should default to in your interview,
uh is cache-aside.
And so, cache-aside, what happens is
that the application checks the cache
first. This is the one we brought up
earlier, right? If the data is there, it
returns it, that's a cache hit, great.
If not, it goes and fetches it from the
database, and then it stores it in the
cache, and returns it to the user.
And so, cache-aside is great because it
keeps the cache really lean. You only
cache data when you actually need it,
right? We're only caching the things
that users actually requested. If a user
never requested anything, it never made
it into the cache.
But the downside is that a cache miss is
going to add that latency since the
request then has to go hit the database,
request the data, the more expensive
operation, store it in the cache, and
return it back to the user, right?
So,
if you're only going to remember one
caching architecture from this video,
make it cache-aside. This is the one
you're probably going to use in the
interview, uh but it's important for us
to talk about some of the other ones as
well. Starting with write-through
caching.
So, with write-through, the application
actually writes directly to the cache
first. And then the cache synchronously
writes that data to the database before
it returns to the user. And so, the
write isn't considered complete until
both the cache and the database have
been updated.
In practice, this means that you need a
caching library or a framework for this
part right here that supports this
write-through behavior. Something that
knows to trigger your database write
logic automatically.
Because tools like Redis or Memcached,
they don't natively support this. And
so, you need either handle this logic
yourself in your application code by
writing to both at the same time, and
there's all sorts of complications that
come from that, or you'll want to use a
library, something like Spring Cache or
Hazelcast, which can automatically do
that write-through for you.
Um but the trade-off here becomes pretty
obvious, and that's that you have slower
writes cuz you need to wait for both of
these to happen.
Um and then also, you can pollute your
cache with all this data that may never
be read again. If we write everything to
our cache, then it might be data that
nobody ever actually accesses, and we're
just bloating our cache for no reason,
unlike cache-aside that we talked about
a moment ago, right?
Um and then write-through also suffers
from what's called the dual write
problem.
This would be that if the cache update
succeeds, but the database write fails
or vice versa, then the two enter an
inconsistent state. And so, you would
need fancy retry logic, error handling,
all of these things to deal with this.
But in a distributed system, this
perfect consistency is incredibly hard
to achieve. So, there's all sorts of
complications here.
Now,
what should you do in a system design
interview? Well, the reality is that
write-through is much less common than
cache-aside because it requires all of
this specialized infrastructure and has
all these tricky edge cases around
consistency.
And so, you'd really only bring it up
when reads must always return the fresh
data and your system can tolerate some
slightly slower writes. If that's the
case, this could be a good fit. But if
your mind is going in this direction,
really be sure that you can convince
yourself that cache-aside or some other
design system doesn't already satisfy
your use case. Next is write-behind
caching, also called write-back
sometimes. And it's really similar to
write-through, which we just discussed,
but instead of updating the database
synchronously, the cache writes to the
database asynchronously in the
background.
And so, the application only writes to
the cache, just like we did for
write-through, but then the cache
flushes those updates to the database
usually in batches later on.
And so, this makes writes much faster
than write-through. We solved that
problem, but it introduces new risk. And
that's that if the cache were to crash
or fail before this flush, then we would
have data loss.
You would use this only when high write
throughput is more important than
immediate consistency or close to
immediate consistency. And so, for
example, something like analytics or
metric pipelines where some occasional
data loss might be acceptable.
But here's the reality. While this
pattern is useful to know, and if you
are an expert in caching and you have a
use case for it, by all means use it. If
you're a novice,
I wouldn't suggest using this unless you
can strongly justify it. There are other
ways to solve the problems that we just
discussed,
um and you're probably introducing
or opening an opportunity for more
questions than your interviewer than you
would like. So,
my honest suggestion to you is probably
avoid it. The last one we'll discuss is
read-through caching. It's incredibly
similar to cache-aside, the very first
one we talked about, except that the
cache handles the database look-up
instead of the application.
And so, on a cache miss, whereas before
the application server went and read
from the database and updated the cache
and returned the value, now the cache
itself is going to do that. So, we try
to read from the cache. If we miss, the
cache goes and requests the data from
the database, stores it in the cache,
and returns it back to the application
server.
You can basically think about it like
cache-aside, but with the cache acting
as a proxy.
And this is essentially how CDNs work,
right? As we discussed a moment ago.
When it when you have a CDN miss, it
fetches from the origin server, caches
the results, and then serves it the next
time.
Um now, as far as system design
interviews go again, you'd really only
bring this up in the context of CDNs or
edge caching. For most application-level
caching, cache-aside is still the best
default because it doesn't require a
special framework or caching library to
handle this part right here, right? So,
you can just use Redis, Memcached,
something simple, um and not have to
have some adapter right there. So,
zooming out now, let's see if we can fit
all four of them in there. There we go.
We got cache-aside, write-through,
write-behind, and read-through. And if
you're anything like me, you're probably
thinking, "These names are super
confusing. How am I supposed to remember
all of them?" And I've good news for
you. You don't have to. Interviewers
don't care if you remember these exact
names or exact terms. What matters is
just that you can describe the behavior
clearly. And so, if you forget
cache-aside, no problem. Just say, "I'll
check the cache first, and if it's not
there, I'll go to the database and then
update the cache." That's really all we
as interviewers are looking for.
And so, it's always better to show that
you understand how caching works than to
just be able to memorize any of these
terms. So, don't overwhelm yourself.
Understand how cache-aside works most
importantly, be able to describe it,
don't stress yourself on the naming.
Next up, let's talk a little bit about
cache eviction policies.
And so, one trade-off of storing data in
memory instead of on disk is that memory
is limited. You can't fit your whole
data set in the cache. At least you
usually can't. And so, you need a
strategy for deciding what to keep and
what to remove as new data comes in. And
that's exactly what your eviction
policies do. They determine which items
stay in the cache and which ones get
replaced when it fills up.
And so, cache eviction policies are
really straightforward, and so we're not
going to make them any more complicated
than they need to be. There are four
that you should know about, three of
which you might actually use in an
interview, one is just good to know
because of its simplicity.
And so, first, we have least recently
used or LRU.
And just like the name suggests, this
eviction policy evicts items that
haven't been used very recently.
In practice, it's often implemented with
a linked list or maybe a priority queue
that tracks the access order, but you're
rarely going to need to discuss the
level of detail that level of detail in
a system design interview.
Implementation for eviction policies is
almost always out of scope, right?
And so, the second one that you have
here is least frequently used, LFU.
Really similar idea, but instead of
evicting based on recency, it's based on
how often something is accessed.
And so, the least frequently used items
are evicted first, even if they were
used recently, right? So, even if it was
just used once, and that just used once
was a second ago,
it's going to get evicted cuz it was
only used one time compared to
everything else that that might have
been accessed more frequently.
Um third is first in, first out. This is
that simple one, right? It's exactly
like what it sounds like. Your oldest
item gets removed to make space for your
newest item. It's dead simple, and it's
rarely the right choice in in a system
design interview.
Um
and then lastly, you have time to live
or TTL.
And so, here each cached item has an
expiration time, and once that time
passes, say like 5 minutes, then the
cache will automatically remove it. This
is great for data that can go stale,
like user sessions or API responses or
any of that.
And so, in system design interviews,
least recently used is the most common
and oftentimes the default. Um least
frequently used makes sense when your
access pattern is highly skewed, meaning
there's a few items that are read way
more often than others.
And then TTL is super common as it's
perfect for when freshness really
matters more than recency or frequency.
So far, caching sounds pretty
straightforward. We store data in a
faster layer, we read it when we can,
and everything just gets quicker.
But in practice, adding cache introduces
a whole new set of challenges, and
they're challenges that interviewers
love to ask about. And so, there's this
famous saying in computer science that
some of you might have heard, and it's
that there's only two hard problems in
computer science, naming things and
cache invalidation. And that second one
exists for a reason. Once you start
caching, new problems start to show up,
things like uneven loads, stale data, or
unexpected spikes in traffic. And so,
we're going to go through a few of the
most common issues that you should be
ready to talk about in an interview, the
ones that interviewers will kind of be
the most likely to maybe probe into.
And so, let's start with what's called a
cache stampede or oftentimes referred to
as a thundering herd.
And so, this happens when a popular
cache entry expires via that TTL that we
discussed a moment ago. And suddenly, a
flood of requests all try to rebuild
that cache at the same time.
And so, even if that window lasts just a
second, every single one of those cache
misses is going to hit our database,
turning one query into thousands or even
millions, and ultimately overwhelming
the database. And so, let me give a
concrete example.
Imagine that you have some website for
which you cache the homepage feed with a
TTL of 60 seconds, right? You don't want
to cache it too long cuz you don't want
it to get too stale. Um so, 60 seconds
is what you choose.
And then we get 100,000 requests every
second.
And so, all 100,000 requests cuz all
users need that home feed, they hit us
in the cache, and everything works
great. But after 60 seconds, it expires.
And what happens when it expires in the
case of cache-aside is that we're then
going to go ask for it from the database
and update the cache.
But in that moment, 100,000 requests
come into the cache, they all fail, and
then they all go try to hit the
database, and they could take the
database down, overwhelm it, and cause
cascading failures. Now, there's two
common ways that you can prevent this.
The first is what's called request
coalescing or single flight.
Both fairly fancy names, but the idea is
actually really simple. When a request
tries to rebuild the same cache key, or
when multiple requests try to rebuild
the same cache key, then only the first
one should work, and the rest of them
should just wait for the results to come
in and then read from the cache.
So, that's the first most common way to
handle it.
The second, which is actually maybe
equally as common, I'll contradict
myself, is called cache warming.
And the way that this works is that
instead of waiting for popular keys to
expire, waiting that full 60 seconds,
you can proactively refresh them just
before they do. And so, say at the
55-second mark, we could come in here
and refresh the feed, um thus giving it
another 60 seconds, and essentially
preventing it from ever actually
expiring, right? We just keep refreshing
it every 55 seconds so that it remains
fresh and not stale, um but it never
expires and causes this thundering herd.
Next up is cache consistency. And this
is probably actually the most common
issues that interviewers like to ask
about when caching comes up. And this
happens because the cache and the
database could return different values
for the same data.
And it's really easy for this to occur,
right? Because most systems read from
the cache, but they write to the
database. And so, this creates this
short window, depending on your eviction
policy, where you can have stale data in
the cache. All right, let me give you a
concrete example to make this click.
Imagine that you have some social
network, and a user updates their
profile picture. And so, that new value
is written to the database, but that old
one is still sitting out there in the
cache.
And so, now other users who are
requesting are hitting the cache, and
they're getting image two.
No, that's bad copy and paste, actually.
Let me update that. Bang, right? All
right.
Image three. Wait, no, I want one image
one. Silly. Okay.
>> [snorts]
>> They're getting the old one, the
original one, image one, despite the
fact that we'd already updated the
database to image two. And they're going
to continue to read this value until
this ends up being evicted for some
reason. Right?
Now, there's no perfect fix to this. It
very much depends on how fresh your data
needs to be, and that is a case-by-case
basis, right? But there's some common
strategies in order to answer the
question if your if your interviewer
asks about this, or if this ends up
being an issue.
And so, the first is to invalidate on
write.
And so, if consistency is really
important here, then when that profile
picture came in and we updated in the
database, then we could also go delete
that key proactively from the cache.
In this way, the next time a read comes
in, well, we would see that it's
missing, and we would go grab it from
the database and update the cache,
right? That would be the process of
invalidating on write, and it's going to
make sure that you're reading the latest
data for the most part.
You can also use just short TTLs. And
so, if some stale-ness is acceptable,
well, you can keep the cache entry here,
but have a TTL that's really short. This
is like what we had a second ago, right?
So, in the case of that newsfeed, we had
a 60-second TTL, and maybe we keep this
around for 60 seconds, then it'll be
gone, and we'll go grab a new one, cuz
we know this is something that changes
often. That's potentially acceptable.
Alternatively,
you might just accept that eventual
consistency is fine, and this is totally
valid. Uh this is for things like feeds,
analytics, metrics, or brief delays
totally acceptable. And so, if I was
discussing this specific problem that we
have here, maybe I would say, you know,
we have a 5-minute TTL on our profile
data cached here, and that's totally
fine. Because what it means is that some
users will see a stale profile image for
5 minutes, and I'm okay with that,
because it's not the end of the world,
and it's fine if they see an old image
for a while. Life is still going to go
on. Okay, right? Maybe that's something
that I could justify based on the
design, and it would be a totally valid
justification to make. Another common
issue, which you've seen come up in many
of the videos if you've watched any of
our other content, is called hot keys.
And so, hot keys is a cache entry that
gets way more traffic than everything
else. Even if your overall cache hit
rate is great, everything's working as
planned, that single key can still
become a large bottleneck for your
system.
And so, for example, imagine that you're
building Twitter X, and everyone is
viewing Taylor Swift's profile.
That cache key for her user data could
be receiving millions of requests per
second, and that one key can overload a
single Redis node or shard, even though
that shard, or even though that cache is
technically working as expected, right?
And so, this, of course, isn't just a
problem with caching. You've heard us
talk about this if you've watched our
other videos in other contexts, too.
Databases can have hot rows or
partitions as well. But it's a common
follow-up question in interviews once
you introduce caching, especially if you
introduced caching in order to scale
your reads, right? So, caching does
increase your overall read throughput.
You're now hitting memory as opposed to
disk, but it doesn't completely solve
the problem if there's one piece of data
that is so overwhelmingly popular, like
with Taylor Swift here.
And so, there's a couple things that you
can do. The first and and the most
common solution is to just replicate
these hot keys. And so, if everybody is
trying to know about Taylor Swift, well,
you can put Taylor Swift on each of the
different shards, or each of the
different instances of the cache in your
cache cluster as you've scaled up. Uh if
what I'm talking here about sharding and
clustering is
not familiar to you, I'm going to link a
video uh on sharding below, but this is
basically the concept of a single cache
isn't enough, so we needed to add
additional instances of caches and shard
our data across them, meaning split our
data across them. Okay. So, now back to
the issue at hand. Replicating hot keys,
right? Means that we'll take Taylor
Swift and we'll put her on each of these
different caches.
And then now the application server can
just load balance evenly amongst all of
them. So, instead of all the traffic
going to this cache or this node, it
could hit any of the three here, right?
Another fairly popular thing to do is
that you can add a local fallback cache.
Basically, use that in-process caching
idea that we talked about earlier in
order to add a cache Oh.
In order to add a cache
here.
Right?
And so, this way, we keep extremely hot
values like Taylor Swift in the app's
memory, so that repeated requests don't
ever even need to go hit Redis. And we
just store them locally here.
Um hot keys, let's see, to wrap up here,
they were really good reminder that
caching helps us scale reads, uh but it
doesn't make your system magically
infinite, and interviewers love to probe
you on that. So, be ready.
>> [snorts]
>> All right, let's wrap up with what is
probably the most interesting to all of
you who are preparing for your system
design interviews. And that's how should
you discuss caching in your actual
system design interview. Well, there's
two things that we'll talk about. A,
when should you bring it up? And then B,
once you bring it up, how you should
talk about it, or how you should
introduce it. Right?
And so, the first and most important
thing is don't just add a cache for the
sake of adding a cache. I see this all
the time. I see candidates who just
assume we always need a cache, they
throw it down without any proper
justification, and sometimes they're
wrong, and even if they're right, the
lack of justification was a red flag.
And so, you want to bring up caching
typically when one of four things is
true. The first is that you have a
really read-heavy workload that's
straining your database. And so, you
could say something like, "We're serving
100 million daily active users, each of
which are making uh 20 requests per day.
That's 2 billion reads hitting the
database." Somebody check my math. I I
did that a little too quick in my head.
In any case, you know, it's more than
our database can handle, so let's put a
cache in front of it to take the read
load off of our database. Cool.
For expensive queries, you could say
something like in the case of newsfeed,
right? Computing a user's personalized
nude feed newsfeed is going to require
joining a bunch of posts, followers,
likes, all of these things across
multiple tables, uh and that's going to
be really expensive to compute. And so,
what we can do is just cache that
newsfeed, uh store it with a TTL of 60
seconds or so, and then serve it really
quickly from something like Redis.
And then high database CPU, this isn't
going to come up in an interview because
you don't have these metrics, uh but
certainly in real life, if your database
is starting to peg out on its CPU, then
it would make sense to add a cache in
front of it. And then latency
requirements, this certainly will come
up in an interview. So, in your
non-functional requirements, maybe you
specified that you needed a
100-millisecond response time on some
API endpoint. Well, then you could argue
or justify that that database query is
going to take too long, especially if it
has expensive queries, and so, you'll
have to cache it instead, right?
The pattern's pretty simple here.
Identify the bottleneck, be able to
quantify it with some rough numbers, and
then explain how caching solves it.
Now, once you've done that, you'll want
to actually introduce caching, and this
is where you talk about all the things
that we discussed in this video. And so,
the first one being, identify the
bottleneck. That's what we just we just
mentioned a moment ago. And then decide
what to cache. Not everything should be
cached, of course. Focus on the data
that is causing the issue, that needs to
be read frequently, maybe it doesn't
change often, it's expensive to fetch or
compute. These are the things that you
want to focus on caching. Think about
what the cache keys are going to be. Be
explicit about this. Especially in
junior or more mid-level interviews, I
often see candidates say, "I'm going to
add a cache here, and that's going to
solve everything." And my follow-up is
always, "Well, what are you caching?
What is your cache key? Uh what values
are in your cache?" Right? So, make sure
you're proactive about that.
The second thing is to choose that cache
architecture. All right, so this is
everything that we were talking about
with cache-asides, write-throughs,
write-behinds, etc. So, you can say,
"I'll use cache-aside on read. We check
Redis first. If it's there, we return
it. If not, we'll query the database,
store the results in Redis, and then
return it back to the user." Right?
And then you'll want to mention the
eviction policy. And so, you'll say,
"We'll introduce a cache. We'll either
use LRU, uh LFU, or maybe you'll mention
that you'll have a TTL for preventing
stale data." But provide some
justification there as it is relevant to
your system.
And then lastly, address any potential
downsides. And so, don't necessarily
just go through the three that I
mentioned, but think about your system.
Which of these are relevant? Do I have a
TTL on a popular key that could cause a
cache stampede or a thundering herd? Do
I have issues with cache consistency,
where I'm going to potentially be
serving data that is no longer fresh,
but instead stale? Uh and is that a
problem for my system, or is it not? And
do I have any issues maybe with hot keys
or anything similar?
If you discuss in this order these five
things, then you'll be a caching pro,
your interviewer will be impressed,
um and you can continue to talk about
the rest of the design.
I think the last thing that I'll mention
is that caching usually comes up during
your deep dives when you're discussing
scale.
And so, when you get to your
non-functional requirements, and you're
either talking about scale or latency,
that's often times the most appropriate
time to bring up caching and try to
figure out where it fits into your
system. And it's super common in these
interviews, so it's a really good thing
to have down pat.
All right, there you have it, folks.
Hopefully, If found this useful.
Um any questions, anything you think I
got wrong, go ahead and drop a comment.
I respond to as many of those as I can.
You'll have the Excalidraw that we used
here in the description. So, go ahead
and check that out. My LinkedIn is
there. Connect with me.
I respond to as many messages as
possible. I'd love to hear success
stories, especially if you're finding
what we're doing useful. And most
importantly, good luck with the upcoming
interviews. You guys are going to nail
it. You're putting the work in.
See you soon.